allez on parle télévision pour finir le
tournage de la saison 8 de l'émission
Ninja Warrior aura lieu du 28 mars au 4
avril à Cannes 180 candidats vont être
sélectionnés et parmi eux peut-être
quelques tours enjaux un casting avait
lieu le weekend passé à Saint-Avertin
dans une salle de parcours qui
appartient d'ailleurs à un ancien
candidat ambiance
à droite Guy 60 ans à gauche Quentin 18
ans tous les deux ont décidé de
participer au pré-casting de l'émission
Ninja Warrior comme ce jour-là 80
participants sont venus se tester sur un
parcours Melan agilité explosivité et
surtout force dans les bras quand un lui
n'en manque pas en tant qu'élève à
l'Institut professionnel des métiers du
sport à Tours il fait 20 à 25 heures
d'activité physique par semaine là où
d'autres ont chuté lui s'en sort plutôt
très bien jusqu'à se balancier qu'il
faut lâcher pour attraper les poignées
rouges
ça s'est passé comme je l'imaginais mais
à la fin le balancier alors que c'est
pas stable c'est des parties dans tous
les sens et j'ai pas du tout géré les
deux derniers exo un peu déçu mais bon
je suis content sur la plupart du
parcours
oui lui c'est un peu la force tranquille
c'est sa femme qui l'a inscrit à ce
casting il n'a donc aucune pression il
est le candidat le plus âgé du jour et
pourtant il n'a pas à rougir de sa
prestation lui aussi a toujours fait du
sport et pratique le parcours depuis
quelques années un passe-temps quand il
n'est pas dans les airs à exercer son
métier de cordiste
[Applaudissements]
c'était très amusant et éprouvant
physiquement le cœur il mon cardiologue
il va aussi me voir il y a pas de
content mais sinon c'est agréable et
puis on est soutenu par le par mes
copains c'est sympa
parce que le gérant est un ancien
candidat et donc c'est important de
garder l'esprit de famille à son ninja
et en venant ici on cherche des
personnes du quotidien donc autant un
boulanger
la personne qui a la soixantaine et qui
sait pas trop ce qu'elle va faire sur
ninjaï en fait ça va être une révélation
donc on cherche autant des femmes des
hommes qui ne viendront pas de même à
nous la prochaine étape c'est donc une
convocation pour certains d'entre eux à
Paris du 17 au 21 février pour des tests
officiels avant peut-être
l'enregistrement de la saison 8 fin
avril à Cannes